you know usually we talk about
controversial issues but we decided to
take a week off that and talk about
something that won't piss anyone off
it's three guys talking about abortion
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
medical doctor and a researcher at the
university of oxford specializing in
medical ethics dr callum miller welcome
to trigonometry thank you so much for
having me here it's great to have you on
the show before we get into it i should
say you know usually we talk about
controversial issues but we decided to
take a week off that and talk about
something that won't piss anyone off
it's three guys talking about abortion
right that's great before we get into
that though tell everybody a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
sure well thank you so much and thank
you to everyone who's listening for
having the patience to hear three men
talking about abortion which i can
appreciate can be a little bit sort of
incongruous um so i'm really grateful
for you for having me here um
i guess i was always surprised to be in
this position i never thought i'd end up
speaking most of my life about this
topic i'd grew up in a fairly liberal
family
never heard anything about this topic at
home or at school and really it was only
at university that i even began to think
about this topic i was never pro-life i
didn't kind of have any particularly
strong opinions about the topic but as i
went through medical school it was the
kind of thing as a doctor you have to
have some sort of opinion on you have to
think something about abortion because
you might be asked to refer for one or
to take part in one and so on and so it
was something that i began to grapple
with
and as i did this i was kind of
surprised because i had always grown up
as a fairly left-leaning person i was
someone who went to medical school
because i wanted to look out for the
most marginalized in the world i went
really to do global health work on hiv
and aids because i thought those are the
people who
most need help in the world or so i
thought at the time and of course they
they do need
significant medical help and support in
many poorer parts of the world
um but as i went through medical school
i began to find that
there was this argument that people came
to me with usually from america
and i admit to being somewhat influenced
by americans on this but they came with
persuasive arguments that really made
sense to me and so as i went through
medical school i began to think firstly
about the reality of life in the womb
and i began to understand the scientific
facts about how human life develops in
the womb i also began to look at the
arguments the ethical arguments which
you could look at from a reasonable or
you know rational perspective and i
began to find those compelling
i also saw the reality of abortion and
what it involves that i had never
learned before and that was a surprise
in a shock to me and then finally i saw
the impact of abortion on women i began
to speak with women who'd had abortions
or were considering abortions and i
began to see that the narrative that
i've been told about it was not actually
true and i think one of the one of the
most kind of shocking or illustrative
things for me was in my obstetrics and
gynecology placements
where we were doing a cesarean section
on twin babies
and it was a really surreal moment
because obviously being a medical
student i wasn't the main surgeon doing
this operation
but i did get the privilege of pulling
these babies out of their mummy's tummy
and that was a really surreal thing to
do but i kind of noticed you know i
pulled one baby out of the tummy and it
was outside and it was a living
breathing human being and of course
there was one baby still inside and i
saw that transition from inside of the
mother to outside
and at one point there was one baby
outside one baby inside and i thought
what is the difference between these why
is it that we treat one of these as a
member of the human community with full
human rights and who deserves our utmost
protection and support
and we treat the other as having almost
no legal rights at all and that really
kind of
grinded on me and i i didn't really
know what to think and so gradually as i
went through medical school i began to
realize that this was an issue i had to
take seriously
and i gradually came round to the
position that actually abortion is
something that is a societal failing
that harms both a child and their mother
and there should be a better way a
better narrative a better conversation
and a better approach where we can
actually support both of those lives and
as i say i gradually became persuaded
that supporting both of those lives
rather than pitting them against each
other was the best approach we can take
as people who are concerned about the
vulnerable and about human rights well
we'll talk about all of that in a second
but yeah it's all this is almost our
first foray into this issue i think we
talked to ella whelan maybe a couple of
years ago yeah just for a brief period
of time and her position is the exact
opposite of yours but i actually i
should say
given that it's our first foray and
we'll almost certainly be talking to
someone from the opposite side of what
you're talking about but exploring your
point of view now my wife is 22 weeks
pregnant today congratulations thank you
and
i haven't looked into this issue
at all really it's not been something
i've ever thought about i have to say
i've i've just gone look it's not
something that particularly is likely to
affect me i didn't necessarily know we
were going to be having children anyway
but my wife is 22 weeks pregnant
there is a baby inside of her that is
kicking that is moving that has a
heartbeat all of that and for another
two weeks under the law of this country
my wife could just randomly go you know
what
i'm not sure
you know that that is the law and when i
realized that i have to be honest i was
quite horrified you know i don't know
whether this is reflective of other
people or just my own ignorance and
stupidity but i sort of assumed that
abortions happen
like when it's a tiny fetus
but actually you can have an abortion
all the way up to 24 weeks which there i
know somebody who was born at 23 weeks
and and lived in in 1985. yeah
so
what is what is the legal situation in
this country just give people first of
all a summary of that yeah well as you
say it's something that really surprises
people and most people don't realize now
it is fair to say that most abortions
are much earlier in pregnancy but it is
true to say that there are a couple of
thousand abortions after 20 weeks in the
country and most of those according to
official data are not because of extreme
circumstances
like the woman's life is at risk or the
child has a really serious disability
most of those abortions after 20 weeks
even are for the same sort of
socio-economic reasons that most
abortions are for
and
as i say most people don't realize this
and viability is now about 21 weeks a
baby was born last year who was born at
21 weeks in two days
and yet as you say abortion is legal up
to 24 weeks pretty much for any reason
in the uk um when people find this out
they're usually horrified and opinion
polling actually shows most people in
the uk think that should be lowered and
actually women have more restrictive
views than men women think it should be
lowered by a much bigger kind of margin
than men do so women actually have more
pro-life opinions than men do in the uk
at least
and so
there are slight nuances to this law so
if the child has any disability that can
be a very serious disability or it can
be a very minor one like having a cleft
lip it's legal to abort them at any
point up until birth in the country for
having a cleft lip yeah so you can look
at the official uk statistics and that
will say these are the disabilities that
abortions took place for and cleft lip
and or cleft palate is
down that's a relatively minor operation
that
that
lots of people have right that's not a
disability well it is completely
surgically correctable um but
nevertheless because the law says if
there's a substantial risk
of a serious handicap in the archaic
terms of the act it's legal to abort at
any point up until birth and we know
that you know
most children diagnosed with down
syndrome before birth are aborted as a
result of that and so it's had a huge
impact on the disabled community
so
that being the case what was there a
particular moment for you where you
thought
i
that completely changed your mind was it
the twins or was it a gradual process
i think it was a gradual process and i
think
that you know it differs between
different people i've had people who
have just suddenly had a moment and say
i get it this is why i am pro-life for
some people i know some of my
non-religious friends it was reading
secular philosophers who were pro-choice
because some of these philosophers say
there is no difference between the baby
before and after
birth and so because abortion is okay
infanticide is okay as well
and some of some of my non-religious
friends have said
that makes sense but
i disagree with the conclusion
because there's no difference before and
after birth i think we have to go back
and say maybe we should value life
before birth a bit more so for me it was
more gradual and that's because i think
you know i want to be a thoughtful
person
it's not just a trivial matter to say i
think unborn babies should have legal
protection
of course it sounds straightforward when
you put it that way but at the same time
that does lead to situations where a
woman has to be incredibly brave and
courageous to go through a pregnancy in
a difficult situation and so in that
sense i don't think anyone can just take
the pro-life position lightly but i
think nevertheless when you really think
it through and you see the impact on
women and you see what abortion involves
i do think that it is the most
reasonable position to take well
let's talk about it brutally and
honestly what does abortion actually
involve because we use that word
so-and-so has had a you know an abortion
or that they're going to have an
abortion from a medical perspective what
does that actually mean
yeah so it's unfortunately a little bit
complicated because there are two broad
kinds of abortion there's medical
abortion and surgical abortion
in this country most abortions are
medical but in the u.s most are surgical
and it differs between country to
country
medical abortions generally take involve
two pills the first of the pills kind of
breaks down the lining of the womb so
that it can no longer provide nutrients
and oxygen to the baby
sometimes this ends the baby's life in
itself sometimes it requires the second
pill to be taken which causes a
miscarriage and expels the baby
sometimes the baby survives even for a
little bit outside of the womb but then
passes away especially before viability
at a late stage these abortions because
the baby can survive outside of the womb
require a procedure technically called
feta side which you can guess what that
means
what this basically involves is
injecting potassium chloride into the
heart of the baby
so that the baby doesn't come out alive
and this has been you know
studied in an academic perspective
people who perform feticide are often
traumatized by it they've
said that it involves stabbing the baby
in the heart and they've said it's
horrific and it made them sick
um
but nevertheless it is what has to be
done in a late abortion to make sure the
baby doesn't come out alive um
surgical abortions are quite different
so in the early stages up to about 13 or
14 weeks it's done by a vacuum so
essentially the baby is destroyed by the
force of the vacuum and is taken out of
the womb that way
and then later on about 14 weeks onwards
a procedure called dilation and
evacuation is needed which is also known
as dismemberment abortion essentially
because the baby is too big and too
tough to be vacuumed and it needs to be
dismembered in order to be taken out
sometimes if the skull is stuck on its
way out they will have to crush the
skull in order to get it out so again i
don't say any of this lightly and it's
i'm very sorry to have to say on a show
run by two comedians because it's it's
actually quite a harrowing um procedure
but nevertheless there are about 9 000
of those dismemberment abortions in the
uk every year
on a baby that probably can feel pain
that is probably sentient and so on and
the truth i think unfortunately has to
be said and i see that as part of my
duty as a doctor and as a human being
i think
certainly realizing some of the things
that are often involved in in abortion
changes a lot of people's minds i think
a lot of people's opinions are based on
ignorance like mine were and still are
to some extent i think
um so but there are a few big things and
and all of this discussion is just
incredibly toxic because you refer to
your position as pro-life and other
people refer to their position as
pro-choice and both of these things are
uh you know the propagandist terms if
you forget you're saying it right that
they just are
but let's explore some of the the real
ethical and medical underpinning issues
that that determine all of this so first
of all when does life begin in your
opinion
so this is something that i've it's
almost a frustrating question because
and
meaning no discredit to you it is seen
as a matter of opinion and as i kind of
said you know when i was studying
medicine and i wasn't pro-life or wasn't
opposed to abortion however you want to
frame it um
this was just a question in basic
biology of the human being that life
begins at fertilization that's what the
embryology textbooks say it's not really
debated
you could you know there are countless
textbooks and journal articles saying
life begins at fertilization and what we
mean by that is
this is when an individual human
organism begins to exist
and it can help to clarify it in that
way
i think what i'd say is that
there's a study that's been done a few
years ago by a researcher at the
university of chicago and he thought
let's get this settled once and for all
and so he did a survey of the public and
he said who are the experts on this
question and about 80 of them said
biologists it's a biological question
life is a biological concept we are
biological things this is a biology
question
so he then said okay let's speak to
biologists and he surveyed five and a
half thousand biologists and said
is it true that a human organism a new
individual human organism is created at
fertilization and he found that 95 of
them said yes and the other five percent
we don't know exactly what they think
but he got some reply saying this is
pro-life propaganda i'm going to ruin
your survey so we can imagine that some
of that dissent was
propagandistic or
i see what you're saying yeah in the
bible and i and that makes sense but i
think the reason this conversation is
being had and i understand why you're
frustrated by the question because
biologically yes
the egg and the sperm coming together in
that way begins the process
but i think most people would also
accept that that fertilized egg
aborting that
versus
dismembering if a a two or three month
old
baby or whatever they're very different
things right and i think
you know certainly for me i think if
you're dealing with a a recently
fertilized egg that's a very different
conversation
to a creature with a heartbeat that you
know and and all of that do you know
what i mean i certainly do and and so so
one of the reasons i try and clarify
what the biology says is to help clarify
the debate
because what we're not actually debating
is is this a human being it clearly is a
human being even when it is a zygote but
what we want to know about hold on
well that kind of depends on your
definition of a human being doesn't it
yeah so you know the standard human
being is a member of our species which
again is a sort of biological concept in
individual organisms i don't recognize a
fertilized egg as a member of the human
race do you well so so what i would want
to say is that there's a sort of moral
dimension which we want to get at and i
try and
say that human being is a biological
concept but we want to know is it also a
person is it something that has full
moral status is it the kind of thing
that we treat as a human being in the
sense of
one of us a member of the moral
community so i would say it is a human
being in that biological sense and human
being is a biological concept but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's a person
and so what we're really debating is is
it a person
well yeah that's what i'm saying like if
i saw a fertilized egg floating down the
street i wouldn't be like oh that's gary
do you know what i mean like that that
is not instantly recognizable to me as a
member of the human race and therefore
what happens to it to in my mind and i'm
working these arguments out and
challenging you on it because that's
what i'm trying to do
what happens to a fertilized egg or to a
tiny zygote
is not necessarily to me
to be treated in the same way morally as
doing that very same thing to an older
baby or an adult human being or somebody
outside of that situation absolutely and
i completely understand that intuition
and i for a long time had the same
intuition that you know this is a cell
or two cells and it's
so different from our understanding of a
person or a character or a personality
and what i think changed my mind on this
was a couple of things the first is that
we have to have a reasoned basis for
attributing moral value and what we're
essentially saying is that because this
you know two-celled embryo doesn't have
cognitive abilities or because it's a
certain size or whatever the actual sort
of intuition there is because it doesn't
have those abilities we're excluding it
from the moral community
and the problem that i began to see with
this is that when you go down that line
of thinking it begins to create problems
for other human beings who might have
lesser cognitive abilities what about
someone who certainly is conscious but
only in a very minimal way
you know i have patients who
are clearly human beings clearly very
valued and loved by their families who
we give a name to and we treat as equal
human beings
but when you actually look at their
cognitive abilities they would have
fewer cognitive abilities than a mouse
or a rat
and so we have a sort of uh
incongruity here that we
don't think mice are people or you know
equal to the rest of us but we do treat
severely disabled people as equals and i
think that's right and the only reason
we can do that is because we share
something in common with them which is
our humanity
so once we go down the route of saying
if you don't have these abilities you're
no longer human and you're not a person
or you're not a moral human being then i
think it actually completely undermines
our entire idea of human equality
and i think that becomes really
problematic so
by this argument
the morning after pill is that a type of
abortion then
uh it's kind of controversial exactly
how that operates so
how does it operate well
it's kind of hard to say so
some what's called emergency
contraception like the copper coil
uncontroversially can act after
fertilization so there's not really any
serious debate that the copper coil does
act after fertilization and therefore
does end the life of a very early
immature underdeveloped human being
other emergency contraception whether
it's desi gestural or something else
it's kind of controversial and we don't
really know exactly the main way that it
operates so it's sort of difficult to
say and i know that's a little bit
underwhelming no that's that's
absolutely fine so callum what is your
position when it comes to abortion do
you think under absolutely no
circumstances should it be allowed
should it only be allowed for you know
women within a certain time frame etc
yeah thank you for that question
um i think what i'd say is that if we
really value human equality we have to
value and protect human life regardless
of how it came about and regardless of
its inconvenience to other people
and sometimes that you know has serious
implications it does mean that we have
to protect human life even when doing so
can be very costly one of the ways we've
seen that is through the covid pandemic
you know so many people have been
through so much sacrifice in order to
protect vulnerable human life and well
of course we all disagree about which
restrictions and which you know rules
should be in place and which of them are
too much i think all of us would agree
that we do have some duty to go to
considerable lengths to protect
vulnerable human lives i think all of us
would want to say at least that basic
principle
so i would say that regardless of how a
human being came about regardless of
whether it has a disability regardless
of how old it is regardless of how
developed it is
if we really think humans are equal we
have to treat them all as equal and give
them all the same legal protection
um
the exception to this i think is if a
woman's life is at risk and you know we
as adult human beings sometimes think
it's okay to take human life even when
that human is an adult we sometimes
think it's okay to kill adults but only
in very exceptional circumstances if the
adult is posing an immediate risk to
someone's life for example or walking
too slowly yeah
well exactly naturally i thought that
went without saying um so so what i'm
saying is in the case of a woman's life
being at risk you're wanting to uphold
life and you're wanting to save as much
life as possible
in most of these cases the overwhelming
majority
actually there's no way that you can
save the baby either way because if the
woman dies then the baby will die
because the woman is supporting the baby
so it's very rare that there's a case
where you have to choose between the
woman and the child but i would say in
those cases what you want to do is save
the maximum amount of life and therefore
you can deliver the baby early in order
to save the woman's life can we come
back to this point because
you haven't convinced me that that a
fertilized egg is a human being in the
sense that it has the same moral value
as a baby or or an adult human
uh or or a born human
because as i said it's not just that i
mean you talk about cognitive ability i
don't think being human comprises solely
of that i think being human is a
combination of a few different things
and and it's are you
mostly fully formed you know human
beings have a recognizable shape
right now i'm not saying that someone
who has no legs isn't the human being
but generally speaking we kind of get
what a human looks like right if a bunch
of aliens that look like fertilized egg
descended from the sky we would be like
those are aliens they're different to us
do you know what i mean so
i do think that you're
and again i'm only putting this out
there as a devil's advocate argument
it's not an issue i've thought about
much so i'm really keen to hear your
thoughts but
like
that fertilized egg
i can it is the potential for human life
and if given the right environment it
will develop into one but to suggest
that
doing something to that is exactly the
same as killing me or you
uh
i i i'm not convinced by that argument
convince me more
so i think i think one of the things
there's a couple of things that we could
say here the first is that we have a
sort of sense that you have to be
conscious or that consciousness is
really important to being morally
considerable i mean if you thought of it
this way imagine that a two-celled
embryo was completely conscious they
were like a little socrates they were
completely like incredibly intelligent
could feel pain could do all these sorts
of things i think the form wouldn't
matter so much to us i think we'd think
this is really weird
but
you know this is something we have to
treat as a morally valuable entity i
think that's true um and so i think we
can talk about form but ultimately
if something has almost no human form
but thinks in a similar sort of way to
us we'd think that is something we
should protect um and you're not
suggesting that a fertilized egg is no
no no no i'm not saying it is but just
for the sake of um imagination and
likewise you know i have had patients in
hospitals that are not really
recognizable in the sense of you know
the human form and you know in older
times where people went to different
countries and saw that people had
different color skin
people in older times thought that is so
different to what the human form looks
like they cannot be our species
and so i think we are vulnerable to kind
of a sort of bias about the shape that
human beings are when really we know
that that's not really what contributes
to them having basic rights or the same
value as the rest but come on you talk
about polling how many people do you
think if you polled the public would say
a two-celled organism
is is a human
not many not many yeah yeah so that's
what i'm getting that yeah absolutely
and and i and i'd be completely open
that
had the kind of complete pro-life view
i'm in a small minority on
um
another thing i'd say on that though is
that
this sort of conscious bias um i think
makes things a bit tricky because we
think harming people is about harming
someone who is conscious if someone's
completely unconscious how can you harm
them how can you deprive them of rights
and things but then i think there are
instances where you can harm people and
they never experience any sort of harm
so for example say i'm not married but
imagine i were suppose i go out and
cheat on my wife
and she never finds out and no one ever
feels any sort of harm from it they
never feel any physical pain they never
feel any emotional pain they never have
any sort of negative feeling from it i
can tell he's not married mate
because that is not a viable situation
of course now so i was just going to say
in venezuela that made you a real man
but
i've clearly harmed someone even if they
never found out even if no one ever
feels anything kind of negative from it
i've nevertheless done something that is
seriously wrong and so that's how i try
and think about the early embryo who at
a very early stage is not sentient is
not conscious i think can it still be
wrong even though they don't feel
anything bad
and
my thoughts about those other situations
make me think actually maybe it is
possible that you can seriously harm
something or someone even though they
never experience the negative effects of
that harm and so i appreciate that from
a sort of intuitive perspective it's
completely counterintuitive and i get
that and i'm not saying that you're
crazy for having that reaction but the
first thing i would say is we know that
we can harm people even if they never
feel any negative consequences from it
and secondly when we do think really
carefully about what is it that gives
people value the only way we can say
that they have the same value is by
something that they all share in common
now we all have the human form to
different degrees
some people have it to a sort of 90 they
look 90 human i say i'm in that category
because i'm a little bit fat and i don't
look like the perfect human form some
people have maybe 50 of the human form
because they've had amputations or they
have a disfigurement to their face and
so on the only thing we all have to the
same degree is being a human and so what
i'm saying is if we really think
carefully about
human equality and what it's based on it
has to be something that we all have to
the same degree and the only thing that
fits those criteria is being a human
being in the biological sense and so
what i'd say is i get that it's
counterintuitive and i'm sure many
people listening will say
i agree with constantine this is
completely crazy to think that this is a
person
but what i'd say is that morality often
is counter-intuitive often when we think
through it very carefully we come to
conclusions that seem counter-intuitive
but when we do do that hard work of
thinking through them in real detail
sometimes that counter-intuitive thing
is the only conclusion we're left with
and that was the case for me on this
issue
hey francis do you like books i only
like comics that's why my favorite
publication is the guardian it's true no
one does satire and parody like they do
so did you have a brilliant satirical
book for me yes it's a book by one of
our fans scott biceno and it's called
identity crisis it has been described as
1984 with jokes so it is like the
guardian no no no mate it's
intentionally funny so in present-day
north west london it tracks the personal
journey of cocksure city boy dave
dalston through a period in which the
government has decided to define
everyone by their ego profile by a
document called the id card it's a
roller coaster ride through cancellation
redemption and spiritual enlightenment
the author has been a fan of
trigonometry from the very start and he
has drawn a lot of the inspiration from
his conversations so if you're a fan of
trigonometry then you're going to love
this book anton we are getting our 10
aren't we
check it out on amazon guys the link is
in the description below
so callum what would you say to people
particularly women who say well it's my
body my choice
i am the one who is carrying this and i
can make the decision
in order to have an abortion and that is
my choice and it's my right
i think it's it's a natural thing to say
and i think there's there's certainly a
grain more than a grain of truth in it
in the sense that women you know often
in history and in many places around the
world and in many places in the uk don't
have the right to basic bodily privacy
you know whether it's forced
sterilizations across the world whether
it's
sexual assault or even rape within
marriage whether it's you know all sorts
of ways that abusers control women and
with that context and so much widespread
mistreatment of women by men
particularly about decisions relating to
their body
you can easily see
why there would be this defensiveness
about a woman's body and her privacy and
so on and i get that and i don't want to
demean that in any way
um
what i'd say is that
when we think about choice we have to
think about choice for everyone and we
you know if the slogan is my body my
choice we have to think about how many
bodies are there now if we believe the
science on this then there are two
bodies that's uncontroversial there are
two human bodies in the situation
um and if that's the case then what
about the bodily autonomy what about the
bodily integrity of the child who whose
life is ended through abortion or in
later abortions is even dismembered in
the way that i've described i think that
makes it much more challenging than to
just say this is my choice
i think all of us realize that choices
can be limited in order to protect the
vulnerable that's why we've all been
going around with masks on for the last
two years because we say in some cases
when there's such a severe threat and
when someone is so vulnerable we have to
you know forego some of our choices in
order to protect the vulnerable
and i think the same is true here that
no one has a choice to end the life of
another human being and this is why you
know the pro-life pro-choice terminology
is so unhelpful
i believe in choice i believe that
people should be able to do what they
want generally it's not as if i just
think everyone should be controlled in
every decision they make but obviously
all of us think that choices have limits
in order to protect other people and so
i'd say that the same is true here it's
a pretty simple principle
you should be allowed to do what you
want but
that has limits when it comes to taking
another human being's life and i think
the same principle is just true in this
case but it isn't the problem that
you're effectively asking the woman to
carry this baby to give birth to this
baby
when
the baby is unwanted and as someone who
used to teach and used to see unwanted
children
every day of their lives it's the most
heartbreaking thing
because you know most of those kids are
never going to stand a chance they're
just not
so what i'd say i guess on this question
of unwanted children is that
i think it's helpful to recall that
abortion was originally seen as a
solution to that problem and yet more
and more these days we have
this so-called problem of so-called
unwanted children now i don't think it's
ever really accurate to call any child
unwanted because i think every child
actually has
infinite human value
in the same way that the woman does and
every child will be wanted by someone
you know
if you look at the statistics on trying
to adopt a newborn baby in the uk it's
pretty much impossible there are so few
newborn babies available for adoption
and so many parents who want a child
that i think calling them unwanted is
probably not very accurate meant
unwanted by the parents right of course
yeah um what i say that is that actually
when you look at the outcomes of
children from unwanted pregnancies their
outcomes are not very significantly
different from children from wanted
pregnancies when you look at the studies
on this
they do slightly worse than the average
child when it comes to certain
educational outcomes
but on the whole most of them are pretty
much the same they have pretty much the
same mental health outcomes and the most
important thing is
do they feel like their life was worth
living even if their life was
significantly worse than the average
child
most of them would still say i'm glad to
be alive and so
i think what we really need to do if
we're concerned about these unwanted
children and their well-being is simply
ask them speak to people who have come
from an unwanted pregnancy speak to
people who have been placed for adoption
perhaps um and
obviously in some cases they will say i
wish i wasn't alive but in the
overwhelming majority of cases they will
say i'm glad to be here and i'm glad
that although it was very difficult to
my mum i'm so grateful to my mum that
they went through that for me and i'm so
glad that i'm here as a result and what
about the women when when they had these
unwanted pregnancies and unwanted babies
what was the effect on their lives well
so this is something that again is
extraordinarily counter-intuitive you
think obviously putting them through
that is going to lead to you know
massive suffering on their part
and in the last few years there's been a
greater recognition even from
researchers who support abortion and use
their research to support abortion
rights and access
there's been an increasing admission
that actually
if you don't provide women that option
of abortion people women who become
pregnant don't want the child even women
who try and get an abortion and are
turned away
the overwhelming majority of them
eventually have the baby they don't seek
abortion elsewhere and the overwhelming
majority of women who have the baby are
glad that they had the baby and i think
we can often get into a situation where
we're thinking
kind of in the immediate situation a
woman's become pregnant
she doesn't want to be and it's
potentially a horrendous situation all
of us can empathize with that situation
and think
that must be a horrendous panic
situation
the woman at that point must feel
absolutely horrendous and most likely
she does in many of those cases and it's
complete panic and abortion is therefore
seen as a huge relief
but when you give this situation time
what the researchers found from this
study in the u.s is that most of those
women who were denied an abortion kept
the baby and of those who kept the baby
96 of them at the child's fifth birthday
say
i'm glad that i kept the baby even
though they didn't have a choice about
it
and so this is a statistic that i think
is not very widely known that when you
actually give people the time and give
them the support
almost everyone comes around and says
i'm glad i had the baby in the end
whereas by contrast in the case of
abortion there are significant rates of
regret it's not that most women regret
abortion most of them don't but a
significant minority of women regret
abortion and we know that objectively
they have poorer mental health outcomes
so when if you take women that have an
unwanted pregnancy and some of them have
an abortion some of them keep the baby
the women who have an abortion have
higher rates of suicide of anxiety of
drug misuse of alcohol misuse and
they're more likely to die within the
following year than women who keep the
baby and so
again it's an absolutely intuitive and
understandable thought a woman who's in
a crisis pregnancy situation surely the
best thing for her to do is for her to
choose to have an abortion and that's
the end of the situation but when you
look at the empirical reality when you
speak to the women who've been in this
situation and you collect all those
stories and voices together you find
that actually abortion is not the kind
of liberating kind of solution that it
is portrayed as actually it is often
another trauma whereas by contrast
having the baby of course is stressful
and i'm sure you'll find this out in due
course
i wish you the best of luck but actually
when it comes to that fundamental
question am i glad this happened
the overwhelming majority of women who
keep the baby after seeking an abortion
are glad that it happened and i think
sometimes all it takes is time and
support and thankfully that support is
is usually available there's one more
question i want to ask for
which is this
right so let's say we we take the
approach of you know banning abortion
apart from in certain cases
isn't that just going to mean that
there's going to be backstreet abortions
that actually what we're going to do is
create an unregulated service which is
going to put these women and
particularly vulnerable women's lives at
risk and in danger
yeah and that's obviously a common
question and a very good one and a very
reasonable one and that's why one of the
main reasons we have abortion legalized
in the uk it wasn't seen as a woman's
right at the time it wasn't seen as
something that we should have it was
something that was seen as a bad thing
but it was better for it to be safe and
legal rather than be dangerous and and
lead to women dying as well and
obviously the women that do die of
backstreet abortions is one of the most
grievous ills of society that we can
imagine what a horrible situation for
her to be in what a horrible situation
for her family um
when you look at the empirical data as
i've done over the last two years on
this specific topic it really tells a
different story so the royal college of
obstetricians and gynecologists in 1966
a year before abortion was legalized
published a report on this question and
they said actually of the women who come
into hospital because they've had an
abortion and
need medical treatment sometimes even
die
20 of those at most have had an induced
abortion the large majority were
actually from natural miscarriages and
tragically as a result of those had
complications and sometimes passed away
but only a tiny proportion of those were
actually from backstreet abortions
and then they noted what about those
women because of the of course there are
not many of those women who were dying
from backstreet abortions there were 50
maximum in the uk each year
those women of course still matter those
50 lives matter infinitely and they
should be protected
but they said what happens if a country
legalizes abortion does it suddenly make
it safe and prevent those women from
dying and the royal college of
obstetricians and gynecologists said
when you look at the other countries
that's not the case
when you look at the experience of
eastern europe which legalized abortion
prior to that it didn't necessarily lead
to fewer deaths in sweden it didn't lead
to fewer deaths what you actually find
in many countries is that because
legalized abortion encourages abortion
and increases the numbers what it can do
is increase the number of women dying
from backstreet abortions we've seen
that in the netherlands in the 60s in
rwanda about 10 years ago in ethiopia
about 15 years ago
in many cases
in fact in most cases the trend is that
women die from abortions and this
decreases over time
but when abortion is legalized the same
trend carries on
in some countries when abortion is
legalized it goes back up and by
contrast in countries that ban abortion
like poland or chile about 30 years ago
that trend carried on going down so
women were dying from abortion but they
were getting fewer in number all the
time
then poland and chile banned abortion
and still the number kept on getting
smaller and smaller and so what i found
on this particular question is that
women dying from abortion is of course a
tragedy
but it's not really resolved by any
legal change on abortion it's resolved
simply by better health care better
emergency care and so i published a
paper on this recently which people who
want to know more can read about if you
go on my website it's a paper about
illegal abortion in malawi so more can
be read there well it's really
interesting because
your
position
is not
widely held
by people in the public eye in the uk of
course i think that would be fair to say
i think you'd acknowledge that and yet
i'm sitting here listening to you and
we're supposed to believe that people
who hold your views are some kind of
moral monsters who
uh
and i'm not i'm not i'm not seeing the
the moral monstrosity in your argument
in many ways i find it odd the you know
the realization of you know my my babies
kicking inside my wife's
womb and and it has a heartbeat and
and by saying that maybe i i don't think
you should just be able to just kill
that baby for your own convenience right
this second which you're legally allowed
to do i don't think saying that
is a moral monstrosity
in fact i think saying that
not saying that
is a moral monster not saying you
shouldn't be able to just kill a baby at
that point
so why is it that your view
is so
demonized and
so
difficult to express in the public
domain without you know i've seen your
interviews in the mainstream media let's
just say they're not giving you as much
of a fair hearing as we are got a bit
feisty on the old beat didn't it it did
it yeah i was a victim of bbc neutrality
yeah
so why is your position so demonized and
why is it that we think that look i
understand why people want to ensure
that women have the freedom to do with
their body what they want to do that
instinct is perfectly understandable to
me as someone who really respects bodily
autonomy and thinks it's very important
but i equally understand that also there
is another life involved right and
there's a tension between the two and
there's maybe a line to be found between
those things and your position might be
a bit extreme for most people but
you don't strike me as someone who's
coming from a terrible bad place and yet
if if if the pr for your position is to
be believed then you are evil people who
who want to control women and oppress
them and whatever why is it that you're
so demonized yeah great questions yeah
good question i think it's probably for
a few reasons one is that
um part of the general polarization in
society you know
you're demonized for some of your
positions
it's um it's part of you know our
society which is failing to talk to each
other and failing to just be charitable
towards each other um you know when i
found when i've spoken to people who
perform abortions you know leading
abortion advocates in this country i
have a friend who is one of the leading
abortion advocates in the country and we
get on absolutely fine we get on very
well and it's because we trust that we
have you know we're talking in good
faith we can actually have a
conversation we'll be honest
and people don't talk anymore they go on
social media and they complain and they
alienate each other and so i think part
of it is just
not meeting pro-lifers you know if you
walk around england you're not going to
bump into a pro-lifer very often you're
not going to hear them out or listen to
what they actually believe and so i
think that's a part of it um i think
part of it is sort of exported from
america where you know we see pro-life
americans as also being crazy capitalist
and all in favor of guns and shooting
people and all sorts of other sort of
there's all sorts of ideological baggage
you know we see pictures of people
outside abortion clinics shouting that
women are murderers
and i think part of it is that there's
been a sort of
exploitation of
that image of pro-lifers to the uk um i
don't even think that's accurate in
america i mean in america there are 4
000 crisis pregnancy centers looking
after women in crisis pregnancies
they outnumber abortion providers by
many many to one
and when you add all the kind of
pro-life work in the u.s up
it's the pro-life help which just
practically helps women on the ground
that vastly outnumbers and outweighs any
other pro-life activity that americans
do but those sorts of things are just
not known um and so i think you know
there's a lot of bad pr and so on and
then i think some of this is obviously
you know deliberate there are people in
powerful positions who have a narrative
and want to portray pro-life as
evil people because they know that
that's the easiest way to stop us having
a real conversation and so i think you
know you get plenty of that whether it's
the royal college of obstetricians and
gynecologists whether it's certain media
outlets you know people have access to
grind and
for some people
this image of us is convenient even if
it's not very accurate so speaking of
having the conversation
what if you were in charge of the world
if you're king of the world for a few
days what legislative changes would you
make what would you ban all abortion
completely or what other what measures
would you introduce to to regulate this
particular issue
i i think it's you know there's a
there's a question of what would be
practical if i was a dictator things are
very different
well in an ideal world what would you
like to see because once you get to the
practical stuff you start to compromise
on value so if you believe that that as
i go is a human life well you can't
really compromise with that because all
at least in our society because we
believe that human beings have a right
to life right
so what i would say is that in an ideal
world i would want no women to ever feel
like she wanted or needed no but but
sorry when i said in an ideal world what
i mean is where you could
you could enforce
a law that you believed was correct i
don't think you're going to get ever to
a position where no woman wants to have
an abortion
that's right but but i do think actually
you can put in place laws which help
get to that position i think yeah
obviously there will always be
situations desperate situations where a
woman feels like she wants and needs an
abortion what i would say is that you
can get to a point where that's very few
women um so i would so i would say
you have to think that the approach that
we have here is that both lives matter
in this situation i think it's inhumane
to take away that option from women
putting the burden of pregnancy on her
while at the same time walking away from
her and expecting her to shoulder that
burden herself so i would say we have to
have responsibility from society that
they gather around women and support
women who feel like they need an
abortion
so to give them the practical materials
the relationships the support that she
needs to go through that pregnancy
there should also be support from the
father and one of the things that we
haven't spoken about is in my view the
way that abortion has facilitated male
irresponsibility there's actually a
really um
really interesting paper from a nobel
prize-winning economist george akeloff
and his wife who is actually president
biden's
uh treasury secretary
and this is from the 90s where it was a
bit less polarized but not very much and
what they said is that since abortion in
the 1970s what that has done is
effectively it has said it has allowed
men to say to women
because this is now your issue because
you are now the final arbiter of what
happens to this baby
if you choose to keep the baby it's on
you so i don't have any responsibility
because it's your choice to keep the
baby
previously the man should or at least
usually would feel a responsibility i've
done this i have a responsibility to the
mother and to the child and that
completely vanished in the 1970s and
what they said is before the 1970s you
had people being lifted out of poverty
you had children being lifted out of
poverty and you had high rates of
families staying together
once you had widespread abortion because
of that mentality men disappeared
but that doesn't make it easy for women
because it's not as if a woman can just
trivially say oh well that's fine i'll
just have an abortion abortion is a hard
thing for a woman to go through in most
cases almost every case
and so when you had that situation men
were deserting women and you had women
being forced to either go through a
traumatic abortion by themselves or in
many cases most cases raise the baby by
themselves and what you found is that at
that point rather than women being
liberated to achieve more in their
careers which it allowed that for some
women
the women at the very bottom of society
who didn't have those kind of
illustrious careers to look forward to
without a child
they were the ones who were left with a
child and without a partner to help them
look after the child and so what you
found is that the rate of women in
poverty massively increased the rate of
children in poverty massively increased
this was far worse among the
working-class population and it was far
worse among ethnic minority populations
and that is what has caused the massive
disparity in wealth and equality in the
us and in many other western countries
so all of that to come back to your
question which i don't want to ignore
but to say that
in an ideal society part of what the
government should be doing is not only
making sure that society provides a
safety net for these women also making
sure that men step up and take their
responsibility for this situation so
that they look after not only the child
but also make sure that the woman is
looked after in her job in the time and
in all the things that she needs to do
with her life and then as i say provide
that legal protection for unborn
children
so that once you have all of this
packaged together you say that both
lives matter the government is
protecting unborn children and
supporting and encouraging others to
support the woman and the child all of
that together will get to a place i
think where
maybe there will be some women who feel
they want and need an abortion but that
number would be much much smaller than
it is at the moment and that's where i'd
like to get it so to summarize then you
would put things in place for the child
and the mother uh to support them after
birth
but
in addition to that you would you would
ban abortion
except in cases of threat to the mother
uh what about ex like serious disability
yeah so in the case of serious
disability um what i'd say is that again
when
when you look at the studies on this and
again it's counterintuitive
you ask people who have been through
this situation there are many many
studies of women who have kept a child
with down syndrome or something more
serious like edward syndrome or patau
syndrome and
they overwhelmingly say i'm glad i did
this there's one study in particular
which surveys women who have been
through this situation
specifically the situation where the
child dies shortly after birth
98 of those women said i have no regrets
and i would do that make the same
decision again and although that time
was incredibly short and incredibly um
grief-filled to go through that
that was some of the most profound time
i had in my life and i'm so glad i did
it and i would never make a different
decision
whereas by contrast when you look at
women who have abortions in the case of
these dreadful conditions where the
child is bound to die shortly after
birth a horrific situation that we hope
no one we know would ever be in but
sadly it does happen
when women have those abortions in those
situations they describe them as torture
they say it was one of the worst things
i've done in my life and so
i think part of what what goes on here
is we think this is a terrible situation
abortion seems like a helpful solution
to that to limit some of the pain and
that's a natural instinct abortion is
the sort of great reliever it relieves
people of an immediate panic and an
immediate difficult
situation but when you look at these
things more in a more rounded way and
when you speak to women and listen to
their voices in these situations that's
not the picture that builds up instead
the picture is abortion isn't a solution
the pain is still there whereas by
contrast keeping the baby doesn't make
everything rosy as well the baby still
passes away shortly after birth and it's
tragic but nevertheless those women
don't say i consider this a tragedy that
i should never have been put through and
i wish i'd had the abortion they say it
was a tragedy but it was such a
meaningful tragedy that i wouldn't have
had it differently i would have made the
same decision so that's i think what the
evidence shows and i think that should
be a factor in public policy callum
you're making great points and it's it's
genuinely fascinating
and these are issues that i've never
explored and these are arguments that
i've never really thought about
my question to you would be
isn't it somewhat redundant we're never
going to change our position on abortion
we're just not that's not the way
society has gone we're becoming ever
more progressive we're becoming ever
more hyper liberal
abortion is just a done issue isn't it
um it can feel like that way if you're
on my end of the
the debate um so yeah i mean i i think
it's easy to be defeatist but you know
on the other hand there are so many
issues where people would have felt
defeatist i mean every sort of
infrastructural injustice throughout
history has felt monumental and i i
tried to avoid you know linking it to
other
structural injustices throughout history
but we can all think of some um and you
know when you go back 500 years to
something that was just part of society
then
people would have said this is never
going to be ended this is such an
integral part of what our society is
built on
and it would have felt like
how can you take that sort of foundation
away from a building it would just
collapse and no one would ever tolerate
that i mean for example i know you don't
want to go into the examples but i think
it's a pertinent one here slavery not
only was a common practice throughout
human history but actually it was a huge
part of the economic right arrangements
that made those societies function and
yet here we are
more slaves than ever but yeah
but but but we have eliminated at least
illegal uh you know in the western world
uh the legal situation so i i i actually
agree with you on that uh you know
francis is right that i think it's hard
to see
how you get from where we are to where
you'd like to be but it's also we also
know that it's possible that right
historically speaking i think that's
true i mean i watched the film amazing
grace the other day about william
wilberforce the kind of foremost
abolitionist in the uk
and you know the the sort of
rhetoric and the the immense money that
was in the slave trade it was seen as
absolutely formidable it was there was
you know it was such a basic part of
society how could you possibly get rid
it was almost like getting rid of
electricity it's what society ran on but
it was run on the back of slaves who
were human beings with dignity and
honor and and
in my view made in the image of god and
so
you have to persevere because if this is
if this really is an injustice people do
eventually come around and you know i
think people do come around i meet
people in my life whether sometimes
they're christians sometimes they're
muslims sometimes they're not religious
at all
when they look at the argument many of
them do come around and say actually i
do think this is an injustice and this
is a societal problem that we should try
and remedy and i think if you persevere
you can get to that point one thing i
think is really really interesting in
all of this is um
how kind of global factors play into
this now what we've seen in the last few
years is russia make it official
government policy to try and limit
abortions they haven't tried to ban it
but they said we should reduce the
number because our population is falling
china is pretty much coming to do the
same thing i don't read chinese so i
don't know exactly what the media is
saying but it looks to me like they're
trying to limit abortion
because of the population now what i'd
say there is this is
this is a helpful illustration because
it also shows why the pro-life
attitude is very different to the
controlling women attitudes you've had
many societies in history which have
abolished abortion or banned abortion
because
they thought the population was
important and they need to control women
in order to increase the population
ancient rome did this romania did this
russia and china may be going that way
that's not the pro-life position the
product position is
unborn children should be protected not
because it's convenient to society not
because women can be controlled for the
good of society
but because they have dignity and basic
human rights and so
in that sense those sort of societal
shifts are in some ways encouraging
because they show that you know
attitudes can change and they do change
you know for
factors way beyond our control in
geopolitics but it's also something that
i'd really want to separate the pro-life
position from and say
although some of the sort of conclusions
they're reaching are encouraging the
means and the attitude is completely
wrong this shouldn't be about population
which is a problem um this should be
about protecting the most vulnerable
people in society so yeah i think it's
swings and roundabouts and uh would you
would you still think what you think if
you weren't christian
absolutely
um and i have really no doubt about that
um the reason i say that is because my
christian convictions were completely
separate in terms of timing in terms of
kind of the basis from my convictions on
abortion
so i had you know i believed in some of
the basic truths of the christian faith
long before i came to a pro-life
position and i thought it was completely
compatible to say that you could be a
christian and be generally pro-choice it
was really thinking through these
arguments seeing the reality at
university of fetal development and of
abortion seeing the impact on women and
thinking through these secular
philosophical arguments and i mentioned
earlier one of one of my really good
friends became convinced of the pro-life
position he's an atheist because he read
peter singer
we were doing a lot of this debate
ourselves at university at the same time
and we were reading these secular
philosophers and ethicists to see what
they said
and he read peter singer and peter
singer says
unborn children and born children are
not really morally different if you can
end the life of one you can end the life
of the other and therefore infanticide
is okay
and my atheist friend was like
the logic is impeccable but the
conclusion is completely wrong and so he
became pro-life and so we you know i was
in this journey with other people and
but it was really a matter of looking at
those arguments in detail and coming to
a sincere conviction that this is where
they pointed so yeah i know there will
always be people listening in who just
don't believe me they just think you're
christian
that's fine believe what you want but
for me really it was a matter of looking
at those arguments and coming to that
position and i know this is an extreme
question and one that you're asked all
the time so what happens if a woman has
been raped she's now carrying the rapist
child she doesn't want the rapist
to have this child understandably so
what do you say to someone like that
i think the first thing to say is
nothing i think the first thing to do is
listen and hear what the situation is
and listen to the voices of women who
have been in that situation i think
we're in a danger of speaking too
quickly especially as someone who's a
man
i obviously think that men should be
allowed to speak about this topic in
partly in part because they have
responsibility for it
but at the same time i have to realize
my limitations i will never be in the
position of being raped and becoming
pregnant as a result
and so i have to come at this with a
significant amount of humility and um
really trying my very best to empathize
about that situation and the first thing
i would say is that we have to listen to
the voices of women who have been in
this situation because i think we're in
danger of making many assumptions about
them it's a good point i'll interrupt
you briefly there to say that we know
someone who who was raped and who had
the child
and
for her
that was
massively radicalizing in favor of the
pro-life position
so she says it's not the baby's fault
whatever happened happened and it was
not good but it's not the baby's fault
and i've brought up my child to be
the way that i've brought him up to be
not to be
his biological father right um
so
you're right the the assumption i think
always is well if a woman's been raped
and then had the child then she's
obviously not happy
well she's not going to be happy but
we make the assumption that women in
that position are all pro-abortion which
is just not my experience yeah
absolutely i mean so the statistics we
have show that about half of women who
have been raped and become pregnant keep
the baby
and there was a study done of those
women and not a single one said that
they regret it and even of the women
considering abortion when you take women
who kept the baby and who had the
abortion only a tiny proportion of them
said
the thing i'm most worried about is that
it will remind me of the trauma it was a
very small minority that's what we think
we always think how can you you know
encourage a woman to have a baby that
will remind her of the trauma women who
have been in that situation only a small
minority of them say this is what
worries me
what worries the most is the stigma of
having a child out of wedlock or you
know these other societal factors that
are nothing to do with the effect of the
baby
so what i would say is absolutely we
have to listen to women hear what they
say hear women who have been through
that situation and kept the baby none of
them say that they regret it hear women
who have been through that situation and
had an abortion many of whom do say they
regret it but i think there are two kind
of key things to think through here the
first is
the life of the child
we all think that
children should have their right to life
protected no matter how they were
conceived so once a child has been born
no one would ever think of saying
if the woman
feels that the child now that it's been
born is a reminder of the trauma that
she's been through she should be allowed
to end the life of the child no one
would say that that should be allowed so
we all think that in theory if there is
a human being with
full moral status with human rights
their life should be protected no matter
how they were conceived and so the
fundamental question is in a sense is
this a human being a child with those
human rights but the second question
that i've really thought through as a
doctor is
will abortion help
in the situation will it help heal the
trauma
again it comes back to this point where
i said abortion is seen as the great
reliever it relieves a crisis situation
and it seems to sort of
just get rid of an urgent immediate
problem which a woman feels and that's
completely understandable and that's why
so many women feel relief after having
an abortion
but in the long run does it actually
help will it get rid of that horrific
horrendous trauma that she's been
through
i don't think there's any psychologist
in the world who will say yes it will
get rid of that the trauma will still be
there and she will be going through that
regardless of whether she has an
abortion or not
on the other hand is there a potential
that the baby could actually help now
you say in the in the case of your
friend
that actually made her far more pro-life
and some of the limited opinion polling
we have shows that women who have been
the victim of unwanted sexual abuse
are more pro-life than women who are not
when you read the testimonies and
there's a great book on this it's called
victims and victors it's just a whole
kind of catalogue of testimonies of
women who have been in this situation
giving them their own voice so you don't
have to listen to a man talk about this
what they say is
this was the only thing that gave me
meaning and helped me to make sense of
the trauma and suffering that i had been
through and that abortion would rob me
of that
this isn't just one woman who says this
this is a recurring theme time and time
again and what we know is that in trauma
one of the most important things for
healing is finding meaning in that
trauma and the evidence we have seems to
suggest that abortion is worse for a
woman's mental health and subjects her
to further trauma whereas having the
baby and this isn't to trivialize it
because i think it's
far braver than anything i would ever do
or even be in a position to do i'm not
trivializing it in any way
but those women who do have that courage
and go through that what they eventually
find is that it is one of the most
profound ways they could have to try and
find some meaning in that trauma and to
heal from that trauma so as i say you
know there's so much that could be said
about this
especially from voices that are female
and that really have been in that
situation so i don't want to pretend
that this is just a simple issue that
i've you know conclusively summed up but
i do want to encourage people to read
more about that go to my website where
there's more information about that and
and listen
primarily to those women who have been
in that situation because i think they
have the most powerful voices
dr callum miller it has been an absolute
pleasure it's been so so interesting
before we go and before we do our
questions for locals we always end our
interviews with one final question which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
it's such a difficult question because
there's so many things one thing that we
didn't really touch on in the interview
is money that's spent overseas on
abortion so the uk government spends
millions and millions of pounds overseas
trying to change other countries laws
which is pretty much the definition of
colonialism or imperialism
millions are spent on it often through
organizations with links to the one
child policy through organizations that
have been banned from countries for
criminal activity and so on um so i know
this is sort of coming out of left field
to some extent but it's another element
of the debate which i think really isn't
spoken about much and we you know as
people paying taxes in this country
who want our tax to go to people who
really need it to people who are at the
margins of society
i think it's really really concerning
that it goes basically to abortion and
promoting abortion in countries where
the public don't agree with it um and so
i think that's something that we really
need more of a conversation on um in
this country about in particular well
thank you for coming on the show and
bringing all of those points to our
attention we really appreciate it if
people want to follow up on this and
read more of your work and find out some
of some of the detail of what we've been
talking about where's the best place to
do that well thank you for that
opportunity um so i have a website
called callumsblog.com it's very simple
but one thing i just want to highlight
on there is that i've tried to put
together all the common questions on
abortion and say more than i have done
today so if you're not convinced by
something as i'm sure you're not um
please do go ahead to that website and
there will be more information available
if you want to get in contact as well
i'm more than happy to answer questions
so thank you so much constantin and
francis for having me on it's been
really a delight and i'm so grateful no
thank you so much for coming on we're
going to ask you a couple of questions
for our locals only supporters but in
the meantime thanks for coming on and
thank you for watching and listening we
will see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7 pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
he actually thought pro-lifers were a
nuisance he we pissed him off
and he was quite open about that but he
said he was surprised when he looked at
this evidence he thought abortion would
help things but he had to stick to the
scientific evidence and he said this is
what it shows
[Applause]